[Music]
i've always loved your name you have
such a beautiful name malin and it's a
swedish name isn't it it's a very
swedish name it's actually such a
traditional name it's like a gertrude or
a rose here so literally when i'm in
sweden
you hear the name mullen but it'll be me
and five 85 year old women turning
around at the same time so no one's had
that name in a long time right exactly
and and malin is ackerman in in sweden
does that have a real swedish
pronunciation it does it's actually an a
with a ring on top like an angel like
the angel that i am
uh that sounds like a line that sounds
like the line i should use on you
like the angel that you oh god
but it's actually pronounced
like okay man
it sounds like a roster thing yeah
like the swedish chef yeah yeah oh so
it's all that you know the
it does sound like uh on the muppets the
swedish chef had that kind of
sing-songy yeah it's like it's the
cadence it's like the herd it already
burned it out
it's really sad i'm glad you're doing it
because
if i did that it would be offensive but
you just did it i did yeah my husband
actually thinks it sounds like a martian
language but he's from italy so he's
like my language is so beautiful which
it kind of is your husband mocks you and
says his language is more beautiful he
does yeah italian is so fantastic it is
you can't really argue with that oh you
got some italians in the house
yeah but it is just like when i'm in
italy and you just hear them speaking
and you think whatever man it's just oh
this is fantastic just say it in your
language yeah it's about even if they're
telling you to f off it's literally like
if they say it in italian you're like oh
say it again fantastic
[Music]
but it's such a
there's a sing-songy quality that you
were just doing and sweet the the
swedish people have that kind of erred a
girl or you know is it
do you find that that's true in in like
uh in
in in their songs does it send us
everything they do have that song it is
it's very interesting because
uh you know
the happy birthday song for instance is
the same in every language same melody
in every language in every language
exactly ours is completely different and
the lyrics are like you know i hope you
live till 100 years and when you've
lived 100 years we're gonna shoot you
and push you in a in a wheelbarrow
literally that's that's what happened oh
yes
the lyrics are i hope you live to a
hundred yeah and then we're gonna put
you in a wheelbarrow yeah we're gonna
shoot you and put you in a wheelbarrow
is that supposed to be like a funny
thing or is it a real threat of death
it's a real threat like a lot of people
die at like 99 and a half it's really
weird they just drop like flies i wonder
why right sweden used to be lousy with
people over 100 years old so they had to
do something instituted this policy what
does that what is that does that song
sound like scary or no it sounds
in a million years that you were issuing
a death threat yep
because it's sing-songy we will get you
that's so scary